[Music]
well as half an Irishman I'm entitled to
say as the Irishman apocryphal a did
when asked the road to London I wouldn't
have started from here the exceptional
ization of Donald Trump to which you've
just been listening is absurd Donald
Trump's been the president of the United
States for less than two years did the
chaos in the world start less than two
years ago it's utterly ridiculous the
crooner your idol
nice suit Barack destroyed Libya and
turned it into a slave market and a
jihad market for at least seven heavily
armed different Islamist groups wasn't
Trump that did that was Obama that did
that you have the goal to pray and eat
George W Bush is somehow better than
Donald Trump George W Bush and your
other hero Tony Blair killed a million
people in Iraq and rising spawned Isis
cascaded across the world you see how
happy how smug you are about the
rules-based society that we had before
Donald Trump 23 months ago 22 months ago
where was the rules-based order in the
invasion and occupation of Iraq and
utterly illegal act the consequences of
which will still be feeling in a hundred
years from now where was the rules based
in the destruction of Yugoslavia no
international law no United Nations
Security Council unilateral use of
Western power deployed by the people
you're trying to persuade us we're
better than Donald Trump
Vietnam was leveled bombed back to the
Stone Age
drowned in chemical weapons by Richard
Nixon and by Lyndon Johnson they were a
part of this rules-based complacency of
which you speak and in aid of your
argument you draw attention to the fact
that populist SAR coming to power the
populist SAR coming to power precisely
because of the failure of your
international order precisely because of
the failure of your orthodoxy it's
because neoliberal politics totally
filled in Italy that you have the
government in Italy you have d2 in
Hungary get all the rise although it
stopped now you may have noticed that
Mellon strong with whom I agree in every
particular is now the most popular
politician in France not lepen she's
gone off for psychiatric treatment the
the rise of Trump the rise of carbon the
rise of the right and the populace in
Italy are all because of the failure of
this order which you so smugly wish to
return us to I don't think it was about
foreign policy too much to be honest the
reason these populist have been so
successful is because of domestic
discontent separate forum yes you can
the average voter on the doorstep who's
voting for Donald Trump is not talking
about Syria they're talking about jobs
really the reason for the rise of the
populist in Italy is why because the
country has been flooded by millions of
refugees from the wars begun by your
heroes first of all let mines himself as
long as I think you're both getting a
very fair crack for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you